enfin pour moi ce n'est pas une question
de mois c'est à dire que on peut
considérer qu effectivement il a commis
les actes illégaux qui sont condamnables
pour autant on n'est pas d'accord avec
le fait qu'une personne soit puni de
mort si c'est toute la question est de
savoir si l'accusé d'une voix lasse et
pour moi ces deux questions différentes
mais estime que le plus dans l'hypothèse
il a été fondé d'abord dans l'hypothèse
d'un d'une activité pendant du d'une
d'une fin de vie qui serait criminel ce
qui me peine qui me dérangerait plus ce
qui n'est pas été jugée tout simplement
et qui n'est pas fait face à la justice
de ce pays
j'ai une question à vous poser donc plus
personnel donc c'est vrai que vous avez
vraiment parler de votre père avec
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé beaucoup de
nostalgie vous nous avez fait part du
manque que vous avez prouvé et
horrifique de personnes par dont on est
le fils de quelqu'un un chapeau oui bien
sûr non mais c'est pour ça que je je je
m'identifie à cette relation qu'on peut
avoir un père à l'affection qu'on peut
avoir pour un père plus encore quand il
a disparu de manière brutale donc ma
question c'est je voudrais savoir si
vous êtes capable de lui reconnaître des
torts de manière je suis très très sur
la défensive
aujourd'hui je me demande dans quelle
mesure nous d'être capables de
reconnaître des torts donc dans ces
activités illégales en tout cas à minima
we will et or est passé compliqué
j'imagine il a une carrière plus de 2
puis de 20 ans la lande est en train de
parler de la toussaint alors que ce
qu'on ressent une carrière le grand 93 %
cette année c'est une carrière le grand
banditisme et c est ce que c'est une
carrière batch et une carrière s'est
condamnée par la loi
j'ai alors voulu choquer bonne foi car
mais ils ont choisi comme gainsbourg
chante bonnie and clyde tout le monde
trouve ça génial si leurs situations de
deux assassins je suis désolé ce par un
vrai faux mais c'est aussi une question
je vais en angleterre je reviens encore
là dessus n'est pas la chasse à c'est un
braqueur et là on a aussi les jours avec
je sais pas quoi parfum de deux
criminels de chez paco de tueurs il n'a
jamais été condamné en france pour aux
héros meurtre 0 meur qu'il était
condamné à 30 a su il était condamné
uniquement pour les braquages et surtout
pour ces [ __ ] d'évasion parce que ça
ça énerve beaucoup de systèmes
quand un mec est mis au quartier de
sécurité qu'on a fabriqué spécialement
produit à la santé réussi à se marrer la
même chose qu'il ait fait au canada
quand on le met dans le alcatraz version
version québécoise où c'est encore pire
pire mais le 10 fois pire que les qhs
version la santé après si elle est
effectivement le meurtre des gardes
forestiers
quand on fabrique des fauves faut pas
s'attendre que les mecs quand ils sont
en liberté
agissent comme des agneaux quoi